pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame alliot matériaux vous êtes là
vous ai pas entendu l'entrée vous savez
qu'à cause de vous je viens de me
trouver dans une situation très
embarrassante à cause de moi mais
témoigne olivier jean oui voila je suis
monté dans la faute heures avec mon
voisin de palier pendant le voyage et
que ça tient très bien
il regarde le plancher le plafond il
compte ses clés enfin bref l'attitude
qu'on peut espérer d'un homme bien élevé
dans un ascenseur
mais à peine ça vous fera sentir et
eiffage ne vous fiez pas à peine
sommes-nous arrivés sur le palier
changements à vue il se place derrière
mon auto comme pour me suivre chez moi
je sens son regard qui ne me quitte pas
alors j'ai introduit ma clé dans la
serrure et tout d'un coup violent je me
retourne si vous aviez vu son regard
resort ses yeux suppliait mme tamayo
c'est honteux et savez vous ce qui
attire est monsieur je m'en doute on
entendu tout ce produit tout ce que vous
pensez ce qui attirait ce monsieur c'est
le moteur de votre sauter de moutons au
premier
c'est évident entre votre cuisine et moi
il ya pas un homme qui hésiteraient
tenez jacques jacques par exemple bien
avait préparé son plat préféré
et bien quand il arrivera tout à l'heure
je ne suis pas si c'est à moi qu il
sourira ou à votre santé moutons ils
vous adorent ils m'adorent ils m'adorent
ce qu'il dit mais le doute est en moi un
but cruel lambert peut-être on pourrait
peut-être ouvert la fenêtre pour les
jeux sont un jeu où tu mets pantois me
suicider mais non je disais ça c'est à
cause de l'odeur est comme ça sans
sourire pourrait s'adresser qu'à moi et
s'il ne souriez pas autant non regardez
là fait fermer au fond c'est vrai bien
que dans les tribunaux que la vérité est
important mais je suis certaine qu'ils
vous adore vous vous êtes certains que
tout le monde m'a alors pourtant que
vous arriviez à comprendre qu'il y a des
gens qui ne peuvent pas s'offrir un wiki
ça que ça vaut vous voyez vous garantis
qu'il y en a à oui eh bah si tu es mois
seulement une personne une personne une
personne voit l'ex mari pas voilà oui
mon ex mari peut prendre son frigo vous
savez bien que vous adore lui je me
demande pourquoi ils m'adorent est un
homme dont j'ai caché la vie un homme
qui s'il n'avait pas rencontré aurait pu
avoir une existence heureuse avec une
femme gentille des enfants un pavillon
en banlieue alors qu'il est il
rentrerait chez lui sa femme
l'embrasserai elle y aurait préparé un
bon petit dîner après ça il a livré la
télévision et différence frottant les
mains
chérie si tout va bien cette année on se
paye la couleur
au lieu de ça il a épousé je vais pas
rendu heureux moi je ne voulais ni
d'enfants ni télévision
alors après cinq ans de mariage et
décrété que nous mari était un raseur
qu'il m'a empêché de finir j'ai demandé
le divorce est gelée obtenu est vrai
tout çà vous prétendez qu'ils m'adorent
oui mais moi ce que je sais c'est qu'au
jour de l'an quand il ya vous présenter
ses voeux eh ben il a l'air
les amoureux de vous non et puis c'est
vous je crois bien que vous avez raison
je me rappelle même la phrase qu'il m'a
dit la dernière fois
quel dommage que les années une patte
pas plus fille je vais l'appeler souvent
lorsque ces gens filles
bah quand même ils exagèrent enfin que
veut-il que je vois tous les jours
d'ailleurs j'ai pas le temps savait
quels postes supprimés le dimanche matin
le dimanche
le dimanche je me le garde il me faut ma
grasse matinée
mon petit match de football lafa midi et
puis ma petite soirée de lecture avec la
vie qu'on mène on a besoin de se
retrouver seul si encore il aimait le
football moi je reviendrai bien au match
de temps ils acceptent très sûrement
moi je sais ça je sais et nous regardent
avec moi pendant toute la partie et nous
cacherait montplaisir nombre mais enfin
n'y a aucune loi qui oblige une femme
emmené son ex mari au match de football
c'est monsieur laurent
[Applaudissements]
et oui on dit la cash shop c'est une
surprise pour toi bien trouvé chez moi
c'est peut-être que tu apprécies
machinalement pour aller chez une autre
comme aux jeux steam dire des choses
aussi affreuse un mois qui passent
toutes mes journées à attendre le moment
de te retrouver du mauvais que l'odeur
de banio ligne à chaque fois qu'on te
fait un black tu aimes tu te pourlèchent
s'est exclamé avec tant de conviction
que forcément la nouvelle se répand et
comme par ailleurs aujourd'hui nous
sommes lundi et que le lundi et asseoir
du bien dîners tu comprendras par simple
déduction pourquoi je n'ai pas eu besoin
de commander à son auteur madame alliot
c'est élémentaire cher watson
'cela dit tu pourrais peut-être songer à
madras
on pardonne moi mon amour tu été troublé
par le plaisir que tu attends week du
saute mouton ou non tu es dur avec moi
qui ne peuvent me fait souffrir mais tu
adores souffriront dirais même que c'est
ce que tu préfères les pas du tout j'ai
un goût très vives du bonheur mais cela
faut-il m'échappe sans cesse à peine les
gens que j'ai dit qu'il me glisse entre
les doigts comme le vif argent soit
maguid le mercure comme le mercure
gumbel gentiment jab et 6 2 6 2 c'est
louise aussi tu sais bien que peut tout
me demander et quand je te demande
quelque chose tu ne veux pas chaque fois
que nous nous voyons je te demande de ne
pas insister pour ne voir plus souvent
alors tu me demanda seule chose que je
ne puisse la corde écoute je dispose de
six soirées
je ne veux pas tout à fait sûr c'est
cette soirée je tends consacre 3 le
lundi le mercredi le vendredi par tout
temps en tout c'est en balade ou bien
portante je suis avec toi tu sais faire
à minuit mais parfois [ __ ]
parfois jusqu'au matin vous posez pas la
peine d'insister on avait compris alors
tous est temps que j'ai passé avec toi
ça ne suffit pas mais je ne quittais pas
du lundi matin au dimanche soir cela ne
suffirait pas je suis insatiable
j'ai besoin de toi bon alors c'est
encore désespérée c'est pas la peine on
désespérait de raison de le dire je sais
bien que j'y arriverai jamais te
convaincre de m'épouser
oui j'oubliais si vous pouvez tout ce
que je veux c'est être avec toi tout le
temps le mariage est en plus mais sont
les tensions ne donne aucune raison pour
ne pas se marier et bien évidemment un
camp les catastrophes commence une de
plus une de moi je savais pas ce que ça
peu d'expériences malheureuses
il faut condamner le mariage sans appel
l'expérience nous sommes un certain
nombre à l'avoir fait
on dit qu'en france nous moquons de
chercheurs dans ce domaine c'est la pète
en fait très pessimiste bien sûr il ya
des cageux cgt mais si rare mondiaux si
rome ne saurions de cela j'en suis sûr
je t'aime tant je t'aime tu m'aimes il
même nous nous aimons
mais comment savoir si tant d'amour
résisterez au mariage
si nous n'essayons pas de le seront
jamais oui mais suppose que nous
essayons suppose que ça ne marche pas
crois-tu qu'alors nous reprendrions
notre vie d'antan comme si de rien
n'était nous aurions poser un tort
irréparable à l'idée que nous faisons
l'un de l'autre et tout serait fini à
jamais voilà ce que le mariage pourrait
nous coûter
j'espère t'avoir convaincu ah non même
si notre mariage était un échec
je ne serai jamais été mais il est fou
alors moi quand j'ai à faire un fou je
vais m'asseoir dont points
et je me tais tu voudrais pas que je
sois raisonnable
assis aussi anti je voudrais je voudrais
t'entendre dire que tu es très heureux
de passer trois soirs par semaine avec
moi que ces soirées est clair ta vie et
que tu n'en demande pas davantage parce
que tu sais très bien qu'il est
impossible
un homme est à une femme normalement
constitué d'être heureux en se voyant
plus de trois fois par semaine mais moi
je pourrai mais puisque tu ne peux pas
jeûner comme souvent mon grand garçon
mais des boîtes à son ambition que je
veux c'est notre bonheur enfin ccc ton
bonheur mais je suis heureux que vous
étés retard mais tu n'es pas joyeux mais
je ne perd pas courage j'espère te
vendre joyeux aller raconte moi ta
journée une merveilleuse journée comme
toutes ses longs cheveux de voir une
journée pleine de toi ton sourire
flotter sur mes dossiers ton parfum
épicé mon bureau la vie et la mort me
semblait bel également j'ai passé mon
après midi à rédiger des contrats
j'écris en cas de décès de monsieur x
dynamics touchera 100 mille francs
et chacun de ses enfants 50 mille francs
et je trouvais ces freins mais aussi
belle qu'un poème qu'une musique mais
demain matin lorsqu'il ne restera de
longues journées avant de retrouver et
que je retournerai à mes contrats je
pensais que je suis un homme bien
dépourvu qui ne peut même pas se bercer
de la consolation que sa veuve touchera
100 mille francs
j'ai quelque chose pour toi un cadeau
mieux que ça relève cyclothymique
que faire si l'homme que vous aimez est
cyclothymique la cyclothymie est
caractérisée par l'alternance de
périodes de surexcitation et de
dépression mélancolique
ça c'est toi si l'homme que vous aimez
en est atteint la première précaution à
prendre concernant votre propre
équilibre c'est oui bon poisson
voilà pour toi trouvait lui une activité
pour ces périodes de dépression
si les bricoleurs car c'est quelque
chose et demandez lui de le réparer s'il
est passionné par l'automobile
dites-lui chéri
j'ai remarqué que la voiture si à gauche
à condition bien entendu qu'elle ne tire
pas à gauche
il ira l'essayer ne trouvera rien vous
jugera un peu sotte et se sentira mieux
je ne suis pas bricoleur et je ne
connais rien aux voitures s'il aime lire
tu aime lire les mli
dites lui que vous ne comprenez rien aux
derniers marcuse il si plongera pour
vous l'expliqué jacques mon chéri j'ai
rien compris aux derniers marqueuses il
est évidemment difficile de comprendre
ce qu'on appelle bon comment veux-tu moi
j'ai pas le temps je dessine des robes
toute la journée je suis plongé jusqu'au
cou dans la mode marcuse aussi tu sais
tu m'expliqueras 1
et c'est promis depuis que je te connais
je n'ai plus envie de lire
je vis c'est mieux mais enfin je vis un
jour sur deux comme ça tu vieillira
moins vite
quoi qu'il en soit la conclusion de
l'article est formel ne cédez pas à ses
caprices vous ne feriez qu'aggraver son
mal alors cet article est stupide qu'il
a écrit et qui accorde du crédit à ce
qu'écrit poulets faut d'abord qu'elle
réussit sa propre vie avant donner des
conseils aux autres nombreux profils qui
est même pas capable de garder l'homme
plus de six mois et sa semelle de
conseiller des autres femmes prophètes
de malheur oui empoisonneuse latter
millions de lettres mais c'est ça qui
est grave elle reçoit souvent des
lettres de remerciements aux lectrices
empoisonné contente
celui qui arriverait à empêcher pour le
décrire il mériterait une médaille il
agit pas pourquoi ne pas très tu pas
avec elle et momo nous ne sommes pas
ensemble way that occuperait et puis
elle pendant ce temps là bas à l'écrire
réponse merci trouve autre chose
aucune on ne trouvait rien les soins
avec traite ma tristesse c'est quelque
chose qui me vient de toi
dj les choses à dire un poème écrit avec
des là ont tous les bons pareillement
été encore il est des deux pôles en
réalité la plupart des problèmes
tragiques ont été écrits par des hommes
heureux seulement il ne le disait pas
elle a alors comment elle s'est tue je
devine tony si oui mais moi aussi si
j'étais heureux je pourrais écrire des
poèmes de beaux poèmes triste il
suffirait qu'au lieu de m'exiler la
moitié de la semaine comme tu le fais tu
veux bien accepter auprès de toi tout le
temps non alors qu'est ce que j'écrirai
mais des volumes de volumes ont été très
vexé parce que j'aurais pas le temps de
ligne non non non je retire ce que je
t'ai dit à propos de paul oui c'était
une idée qui a d'abord val-des-bois
libre
et puis enfin comment penser que tu
puisses te plaire en sa compagnie de
plus elle est horriblement bavarde elle
pourrait te dire des choses sur moi des
mensonges des calomnies
vous pourrez et elle me dire de si
terrible ah c'est à dire je les
écouterai pas tu sais ce genre de propos
on ne les entend pas mais il reste quand
même et ça laisse des traces
assassiné non le bas alors alors alors
il n'y a pas que le van natta cité fini
il y a que j'attendais moi ça vaut au
sublime par le gong
oh
oh non au nom le mardi c'est une bonne
journée pour le malawi une bonne journée
parlons-en moi je me sens complètement
inutile vous n'avez pas besoin de mes
services pour mettre un filet de citron
sur une salade verte
il n'y a pas de rage mineurs pour un
véritable artiste
même vos salades aux citrons sont les
chaleurs le temps denis des neurones je
dis que j'aimerais mieux ne pas avoir le
temps de lire des horreurs là le journal
assure le journaliste et vous là là sur
le modèle là je me passionne horrible là
dedans mais si ces hommes là les
cyclotouristes imik si mik cyclothymique
oui c'est ça eh bien vous savez la ville
doit pas être facile pour eux au mal à
mayo cyclothymique
tout le monde est plus ou moins c'est
monsieur mais oui sept heures
ce ailleurs
voyez j'ai pigé le marché rage est
restée mariée
de quel marché s'agit-il
ken mars et mi mai elle est inouïe mais
le marché le vrai le seul l'unique
la plus grosse affaire de ma carrière un
contrat publicitaire de 800 millions je
vais courir la france d' affiches et toi
toi j'étais courir un bijou c'est pas la
peine mais si c'est l'appel ce contrat
c'est à toi que je le dois c'est auprès
de toi que je puise la force de
triompher mais c'est l'ambition c'est
être un peu vite at il m'est
indispensable sans toi je serai un être
incomplets un de ces pauvres types qui
traîne son but sans faire sans moi mais
avec tes amis
c'est vrai on dirait que tu peux pas pas
tu es petit tu les vois pas trois ou
quatre fois par semaine
tu te suis partout montre un nom alors
écoute ne fais pas ta jalousie les
pâtons gens tués une femme intelligente
toi qui sais qu'un homme a besoin
quantité égale d'amour et d'amitié tu le
sais et tu l'admets je l'admets lorsque
j'y suis obligé
non mais parce que tu sais que c'est
beaucoup mieux aussi pour nous deux
aurait-il eu plaisir à me voir si soir
après soir je montais c'est toi et te
raconte éternellement les mêmes
histoires alors que grâce à notre
organisation se te laisse juste assez de
temps pour t'ennuyer un petit peu mais
m'accueillir ensuite comme le messie
évidemment et si de ton côté tu faisais
moi plus souvent tuerait moins envie de
voir à temps at-on mehmed mois - alors
nous faisons bien le mardi le jeudi et
le samedi nous passer la soirée ensemble
et le reste du temps nous faisons ce que
nous voulons
et oui moi je vois mes amis et toi tu
t'ennuies un petit peu
tu n'as pas peur que je m'ennuie trop tu
peux voir pau au pôle
non mais tu es une femme qui travaille
tu as besoin chaque semaine d'avoir des
soirées tranquilles des soirées bien à
toi ou je fais ce que je veux
et oui tout ce que je veux ah oui sans
que je viens de forêt monde est dans tes
petites occupations
ces petites occupations tu veux pas
savoir ce que mes sets mais ça ne me
regarde pas tu es libre aussi libre que
moi la femme est l'égal de l'homme
j'aurais parfois tendance à l'oublier à
me sentir coupable quand juste de ma
liberté
après tout j'en ai le droit j'irai plus
loin du n'en a pas le droit
tu en ahl de boire nous sommes des gens
merveilleux
nous avons résolu le problème du couple
non nous sommes intelligents ce tous à
l'eau aux sétois
mais si ça m'ennuie ça peut pas attendre
de ces pôles
elle a raccroché à la vie alors on ne
peut pas de bancs et des prêtres content
toi qui me conseille de partir mais
soirée avec oui toi avec elle mais sans
moi j'ai pas ce qu'est là elle va
absolument parler la guerre dans tous
ses états je m'en défaire vitesse et le
juge pas le faire je tiens mon grand il
y en aura pas pour longtemps
bon alors écoute je vais prendre un
verre au harry's bar appel - là bas dès
qu'elle a filé d'aquin et puis non tiens
je voulais dire bonsoir à charlie bas
téléphone vie pour savoir s'il est chez
lui oui
et puis tu seras gentil laisse-moi son
numéro là quelques sous
jb madame alliot givet des pôles
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce qu'ils varient jeu semble tu
vas me le dit alors
alors ça lui charlie salut ma vieille tu
es chez toi
on a vous êtes plein régime oui non mais
bien sûr si tu si tu me réponds c'est
que tu es chez toi non je disais ça sans
y penser c'est passé oui
ah ben dis donc tu as l'air d'une humeur
si je comprends bien ma visite ne
souffre aucun plaisir
bon ben je tends voudrait ça s'allume
avait alors dit moi si tu arrive ça va
te faire un choix robert et moi c'est
fini
sans fin non mais t'es 100 francs dont
la manne voilà mais pourquoi mais parce
que j'avais parié 100 francs avec vous
qu'avec vos idées un homme ne pourrez
pas vous supportez plus de six mois aux
aléas les jeux je vous plains bien bas
merci c'est toi qui l'a quittée où ses
filles s'est séparé à l'amiable
ça c'est mieux ça l'est moins de traces
mais vous l'oublierez vite on n'oublie
pas on accumule homécourt saisir faut
vous ressaisir aller de l'avant l'avenir
est riche de promesses comme disait
saint-augustin 7 du statut cela moi j'en
sais rien mais je suppose
il ya tellement de gens qu'on dit ça
pour quoi pas besoin de buts voilà tout
est prêt pour les dîners merci je m'en
vais bonsoir vous l'avez pas encore dit
oui je sais je suis navré mais j'avais
absolument besoin de parler
non mais vous en faites pas c'est pas
grave merci vous êtes gentil non mais
c'est vous qui êtes gentille ball oh non
mais c'est moi qui devrais vous
remercier pour les vrais amis sont ravis
et je vous considère comme une vraie
amie oui ah oui parce que les vrais
ennemis ça fait quoi ça vous fait du
bien et vous m'en fait merci je suis
bien content qu'ils aient oui oui grâce
à vous je vais sauter un poste excellent
pour la forme ça et alors comme disait
saint c'est avec sa fourchette qu'on
creuse sa tombe
alors voilà pourquoi je vous remercie
pour votre île débat rationnel m
[Musique]
tu veux manger quelque chose lance avec
ce qui m'arrive pas tellement faim je te
comprends d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya paya
des salades au citron le soir derrick
tait le régime strict bon ben tant pis
je gage d'un soir et la soirée n'est pas
fini tu comprends il veut absolument
besoin de parler quand j'ai réalisé tout
à l'heure que repère n'était pas là tu
ne serait plus jamais la quitter en
veine buts et part en contre
dans ces cas là vaut mieux prendre
l'ascenseur ça laisse plus de temps pour
réfléchir
mehdi dont il fallait se jeter par la
fenêtre à chaque fois collègues vous
guident alors il t'a quitté mer et vous
vous étiez séparer à l'amiable
l'algérie même quand elles par la
première c'est quand même la femme qui
ait quitté bâti dont tu sais pas ce que
tu écris dans tes articles s'amusant
j'espère qu'au moins tu crois ce que tu
écris 6-3 oui mais ce sont les hommes
qui me croient bobards tu t'es dit que
si chaque fois qu'un homme te qui ont
chaque fois qu'un homme nous qui te nous
toi moi les femmes en moi ça m'arrive
très rarement la chance mais pas du tout
moi je suis très organisé ça tu
arriveras à toi aussi tu verras tu es
venu pour me raconter tes malheurs ou
pour mulhouse les miens qui à l'heure de
penser que y échappera toujours mais
pourquoi pas il regarde autour de toi
y'a pas toutes les femmes aucune fait ce
qu'il faut tandis système ne durera pas
c'est pas possible les outils systèmes
comme tu dis dure depuis un an je
pourrai pas vivre dans cette hypocrisie
nous faut mieux jouer malheureuse tous
les six mois mais avoir ma conscience
pour moi sa prêche la révolution des
moeurs mais tu résonne comme une
boutique hier mais l'idée qu'il ya deux
hommes + m
j'arrive pas d'où vient ici ici on va
essayer pour une fois de raisonner
froidement et d'aller jusqu'au bout de
nos arguments tout d'abord est ce qu il
te semble possible d'aimer deux doigts
en même temps de les aimer sincèrement
là il raconte moi même je n'aime que lui
bon j'attendais cette question alors je
te pose une autre question as tu jamais
étayées quand tu étais amoureuse d'un
homme dans l'emea nos agents réponse pas
de besoin parfait on va ce qu'on va
changer de sujet un instant puis
rédactrice à bell tu es satisfait de ton
sort tu es en vie
il a beaucoup de responsabilités ni de
bagnes davantage avec le temps bon alors
si je comprends bien tu voudrais faire
plus de thunes fait et gagné que tu as
en somme
tu as de l'ambition alors si on en
revient au problème qui nous préoccupe
on constate que là tu me remets ton
ambition à aimer un homme et un seul
puisque je n'éprouve pas le besoin d'en
aimer dieu n'éprouve pas le besoin parce
que la société de l'interdît ça c'est
parce que la femme n'est pas encore
libérée n'est pas libéré par la faute de
gens comme toi quand je pense à la
quantité de petty ce que tu peux te dire
merci des voies indirectes pour toi être
libre c'est le dur de mon esclavage
chacun son tour
real et on n'en finira jamais de me
lancer la femme de me lancer l'homme et
on recommence
mais enfin la seule liberté pour une
femme comme pour un homme c'est que
l'autre soit libre et avec ton système
il le sait parfaitement et le temps
enfin pourquoi pourrait-on aimé son père
son nom le ton cousin son neveu son mari
son fils ait pas deux hommes
il faut y penser
alors maintenant nous savons la chose
possible et là nous allons voir si elle
présente des avantages
alors moi là le premier qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est quelle est la liberté 11
ans et permet à la femme ne mettront
jamais quand il faut pas me cacher
l'homme n'a pas suffisamment a tonné
pour combler une femme tandis qu'une
femme a suffisamment de générosité en
elle pour satisfaire de l'homme ça c'est
bien vrai si tu savais comme je me sens
généreux et ben tu vois
mais on a peut-être raison alors j'étais
convaincu ou complètement il y as tu
fait rêver pourtant il reste un grave
problème en bas oui tu me disais tout à
l'heure que tu ne pouvais pas vivre dans
cette hypocrisie et bien moi non plus
d'ailleurs pu voir trois noms but d'une
épaule russie enfin pour que je le sois
complètement il faudrait qu eric gens
sachent la vérité n'accepte voilà j'ai
pas le courage de leur dire je fais
parfois des petites tentatives
j'explique un [ __ ] qu'il cesserait vie
d'avoir envie de me voir si vous voyez
plus jour tient tout à l'heure encore je
disais à eric qu'il me laissait trop de
liberté que je pourrais peut-être en
profiter c'est parce qu'il m'a répondu
tu n'as pas le droit qu'on allait devoir
je peux quand même pas lui dire comment
je l'accomplis mon devoir
et puis ce qui est terrible au milieu de
tout ça c'est qu'on est très heureux
tous les trois alors moi j'ai peur de
briser tout ce bonheur
si un jour josette ou leur dire la
fraude plancher c'est ce que dit mme
contart est dit frère alors il faut pas
que je le fasse
n'a pas confiance en moi bas dans ce
domaine vois-tu par tout le monde
ouais il allait perdre tous les deux
mieux vaut en garder qu'un mais qu'est
ce que je me dis parfois alors j'imagine
la vie auprès de celui que j'aurais
choisi de garder
et puis je crois près de norma main dans
la sienne essayant de le consoler et
follement amoureuse de lui
bon ben si on mange à quelque chose un
petit peu tout ça là je vais la chercher
mais manger gaza l'année je devrais pas
interdit c'est inutile à inutile la
salade ça contient des vitamines qui
sait lesquels mais qu'elles me choque
pas moins des vitamines
la vitamine e faire quoi ça sert la vie
de la mine
la vitamine e rééquilibrer l'organisme
devra passer bien dit la vitamine de
l'effort sexuelle
[Musique]
il ya qualité de rentrer tout seul dans
mon appartement vie crime sans glace cet
ennui pense je dors là si ça manque
évident de revenir
je dois même lui téléphoner les petits
sera parti n'a pas t'empêcher de vivre
tu peux l'appeler complet tu me trouves
égoïsmes n'ont peut-être qu'à ta place
en trottant des gencives et sa débauche
les mêmes par téléphone
alors le harry's bar
je voudrais parler à monsieur reid plus
cher pour chérie je vois d'ici aussi
tristement au bar en train de regarder
son bonheur demain on se faire robert en
ce moment peut-être qu'il poids pour
essayer de tout plaquer
jean fera bien autant maintiens ma
chérie quoi ils étaient sûrs même
compliqué tu crois au certainement non
mais vraiment du poids mais oui tu n'es
pas celle qu'on les fasse comme ça ta
mémoire toinon tu t'es cru ce soit
tranquille va signer mon verre non
réponse que tu susceptibles eux c'est
parce que je voulais et je voulais dire
que tu d'incruster dans la mémoire des
hommes
il s'imagine qu'il va se débarrasser de
moi comme ça y est vigilant tu
n'oublieras pas ton monte oh non ah oui
alors oui il n'est pas là vous avez bien
m'en a non merci je rappellerai c'est
drôle ça il m'avait pourtant dit de
l'appeler au arrive pas c'est drôle
largement eu le temps d'y arriver au
charlie mais non je suis bête charlie
était occupée je vais essayer de
l'amener au bureau ben oui c'est
mais pas là non je vais tenir compagnie
ma chérie je sais ce que c'est que
d'être seule la merci kidon si on
soulève il a dû rencontrer lamy je
rappellerai dans un instant on peut déjà
commencer à voir ça tu avanceras à quoi
hein d'ailleurs je te connais tu as
livré ce prix ce sinistre mais ça tombe
bien parce que justement je suis pas gay
alors qu'il n'ya pas compagnie nord il
vaut mieux pas j'ai pris des comprimés
contre la migraine et puis eric doit
revenir tu votes possède un bon scotch
pour un homme qui traînent on sait pas
où on ne l'attend on goûte téléphone un
seul gène j
je
pour me le rappeler ah oui mérite le
plus cher est il arrivé n'est pas là il
n'est pas là voilà ah bon non non non
non il ya merci excusez moi il était
comme ans quand il est parti
beau très beau avec cette terre qu'il a
tu sais jamais rien prendre au sérieux
une norma claire c'est très genre qui
sonne il est tout de même parti vexé
d'être aimait trop retenu davantage
tu crois les quand même pas su plier il
n'en demandait pas temps même si peu de
gentillesse qui était froide mais j'ai
pas été méchante toujours pas pourquoi
tu aurais tu es méchante avec on n'a pas
envie d'être aimable avec un homme qui
vous qui toi tu est traumatisée enfin
coup tu peux plus voir un homme sortir
sans avoir l'impression qu'il te qui va
évidemment raconté comme ça je refuse de
dramatiser on peut vivre
si on dit à chaque fois tu es un homme
sans vagues peut-être la dernière fois
qu'on voit évidemment tu la verras c'est
pas le genre d'homme à rester
l'excellence tonnes
j'ai essayé d'appeler chez lui au
téléphone
qu'est ce que tu vas lui dire dû dire
qu'ils viennent tu accepterais tu crois
qu'il acceptera numéro téléphone parce
que si tu aimes bien on ne connaît par
coeur green les sommes qu'on aime je
laime pas bien je laisse tuer mme robert
aubin au nom non j'aime
eric c'est eric que tu appelé mais oui
bien sûr
ma pauvre chérie tu vois la tête mais
tout ça c'est chagrin
je vais me reposer à 12 janvier n'ont
plus
[Musique]
oui allô
à allauch n'ont pas été trop méchant
[Musique]
diop
tu es malade impétrants pu seulement
déjeuner d'affaires non c'était hier
j'ai été paula se consoler robert l'a
quitté c'est moche ah oui c'est moche
parce que maintenant alors encore plus
de temps pour écrire ses pages charité
on reprend les laver du chagrin
vous avez chaloupés de bar en bas non on
y rester ici pour boire heureux vivons
cachés tu as dû me téléphoner je vous
aurais tenu compagnie non il valait
mieux pour paul que nous soyons seuls
les spectacles de notre bonheur aurait
pu lui faire mal d'autant qu'elle a oui
ça ça vaut être le plombier
il m'avait promis de passer il est en
retard mais là-bas lyon c'est le
plombier
j'ai dû supplier pour avoir un plan
biais de nos jours faut vraiment faire
des passes et madame avions fait le
passé dans la tâche de beurre et tirer
le rideau pour se mettre en qui nous
étions mariés c'est moi qui vous
occuperez toutes ces questions qui
s'échangeait à joindre à nous non mais
je sais composer un numéro téléphoner au
plombier c'est le travail d'un homme
soit interdit de faire du charme note
d'ailleurs les plombiers déteste ça ils
n'aiment pas contente de les séduire
ce sont les protestants du bâtiment mais
mis dans la salle de bain
et bah c'est pas bien oui mais c'est pas
plombier avant non c'est votre cousin
votre cousin eric moreau aéré
oui oui votre cousin aujourd'hui mais
doit abandonner mercredi
messieurs s'était pas trompé toujours
toi là on est mercredi mais oui mais oui
à bombe a fait le patient t mais qu'est
ce qui pourrait bien voir si rarement
faut que ce soit aujourd'hui j'ai pris
sa main avait lieu la vie à la salle de
bains mais j avais dit alors les ordres
sont les ordres de tout concept est en
train de prendre une douche
il a figuré c'est la coutume chez toi
quand on arrive à la dorure à chaud tu
plaisantes de plus en jeu si je ne sais
pas quoi faire moi je fais le entre et
nous présentera non tu te connais pas il
est menteur une vraie commère s'il te
vois chez moi que c'est quelle histoire
il élira raconté à la famille à je
comprends ta famille tu crois que tu ne
recevra jamais un homme chez toi avant
d'être mariée avec mais non quand même à
mon argent enfin c'est presque ça alors
je suis d'accord t'es d'accord pourquoi
mais pour toucher de plus dans les
banques et dans la tête tu ne m'aide
mais le fait qu'ils s'essuient qu'il se
rhabille enfin tu veux que je m'engage
l'état maladie très gentil tu as honte
de moi je le sens bien j'ai l'habitude
de souffrir voiture puisque tu ne veux
pas dans ma chambre de mes jambes
n'étaient pas très prudents à tatum est
pas l'attention de fer entre ton cousin
d'achat au bras nord est passée tout
asseoir avec lui tu sais on est parfois
le longtemps à s'en débarrasser et bien
au pire je m'endormirai en attendant tu
n'auras qu'à me réveiller quand il sera
parti
émile cousin dans la sens très bien oi
dans la chambre voilà
mon atelier table dans mon atelier
tiens c'est occupera si je comprends
bien ça va être long n'oublie pas
n'oublie pas que je t'aime
fombeur voulait sa mort
vous paierez demain
il m'est arrivé d'attendre dans bien des
endroits mais dans une salle de bain
c'est la première fois
je croyais que c'était plombier alors
j'ai dit à ma le maillot de fait montré
dans la salle de bain et madame alliot
ne m'a pas reconnue
et oui quand on voit quelqu'un que trois
fois par semaine allez donc vous
souvenir de son visage
oui je sais pas ce qu'il lui a pris je
plaisante mais tu sais j'ai parfaitement
compris ah ça fait un choc
je vais te dire on se croirait unique et
puis un jour c'est la révélation du
couvre qu'on ne l'est pas enfin côté
ridicule ridicule
tomtom frappant un choc à toi si cette
arrivée laisse moi t'expliquer non je
t'en veux évidemment mais au fond je te
comprends la situation était amusant tu
te disais ils se rencontreront jamais
alors pourquoi pas la tentation était
trop fort non c'est pas du tout ça et on
te l'a recommandé ou tu l'a rencontrée
par hasard en jetons prix arrive ça
c'est choquant mais non mais tout le
monde se refile deux adresses tu
peut-être mais pas moi non écoutez c'est
tout fait en a pas et il leur semble non
vraiment il ne ressemble pas du tout
alors référence je comprends plus
j'exige une explication peux tu me dire
pourquoi madame alliot marie pour le
plombier si le plombier n'est pas mon
sosie de pons aussi et le plombier n'est
pas tout tu me fais marcher
le plombier n'ai pas à m'en soucier
l'électricien nos bombes alors la
vieille aa je suis le seul l'unique et
c'est toi qui m'as veinards tu devais
faire venir ce soir à lons tu m'a privé
de ma soirée d'hier je suis venu la
récupérer les coûts du disque les
internautes intéressés tard faute du
n'avez qu'à attendre au harry's bar que
je t'appelle je t'ai appelé plusieurs
fois je t'aimais rabelais chez toi
c'était beaucoup plus simple de
s'installer dans le bistrot d'en face et
de surveiller l'entrée de l'immeuble
quand on a décidé d'un plan mon site ya
c'est vrai qu'à sinon y'a plus
d'organisation possible c'est comme ce
soit c'est vrai tu viens alors que tu ne
devais pas venir d'adhérence tout le
monde
charmante accueille alors d'abord on me
colle dans la salle de bains mais
ensuite on me fait des reproches alors
que je ne suis pour rien dans tout cela
c'est presque ça pardonne moi non mais à
une condition c'est que nous passons la
soirée ensemble c'est pas très en forme
c'est parce que j'ai je serai pas d'une
compagnie agréable jeu tu acceptes comme
tu voulais me coucher tôt et pas
d'accord cochon et moi je n'ai pas envie
de temps mais c'est la première fois que
nous nous disputons oui oui c'est la
première fois pour la première fois nous
voulons des savants combat de titans et
que le meilleur l'emporté par les
voisins
nous passons la nuit en dessous puis
tiens tellement comment si j'y tiens j'y
tiens parce que j'y ai droit
ben oui je te dois une soirée chocola
rendre est le problème et écoute soit
gentil pas ce soir demain si tu peux non
demain je viendrai de toute façon alors
ce sera ce sens j'ai pu la force de me
battre à me voir
ce sera ce soir mais tu verras ça sera
pas une bonne soirée
enfin ne soit pas pessimiste les choses
se passent souvent beaucoup mieux qu'on
pense
si tu pouvais dire vrai tout bien
réfléchi je me suis dit qu'il ne serait
pas plus mal
présents
monsieur monsieur oui mais oui pourquoi
ne pas faire les présentations
chirac jacques je te présente eric eric
batty jacques joxe et à vieil ami c'est
un avis du tour de mon mari en fait de
mon ex mari
oui nous étions nous étions amis avoir
mon divorce et j'essaie je sais pas
parce qu'on dit parce qu'on doit
renoncer verte à voir les amis de son
mari
surtout s'ils sont aussi vos tabliers
c'est naturel si tu trouves pas que
c'est naturel c'est naturel c'est vrai
vous ressemblez à florence
il ya comme un air de famille vous
trouvez et c'est normal quand on épouse
oh oui oh oui oh oui bon ça on s'est
bien amusé quand on était petits on
jouait aux billes de soldats casser la
figure à tous les petits voyous car je
t'avais des jeux virils turris et
j'essaye de suivre
et quand on a fait notre survie notre
service militaire c'est qu'on a de la
chance on a été incorporé dans la même
unité
moi je crois je mettrais bien m'entendre
avec ton cousin j'apprécie son genre
d'humour font bien rire un peu et bien
moi je suis moi je suis heureux mais
comme un gosse petite rencontre c'est le
premier membre de ta famille à qui je
suis présenté tech médias vous le dire
je suis favori laurence un simple ami ah
non non c'est un peu plus un peu plus et
un peu plus je veux l'épouser mais
demande encore un peu de temps pour
réfléchir pourquoi elle a fait
l'expérience malheureuse de moi je suis
tout disposé qu'elle accepte et nous
sommes mariés tous mes compliments je
les accepte
venant de vous eric je sais qu'ils sont
sincères vous permettez que je vous
appellerai mais jeu mais je vous en prie
ils seront bientôt de la même famille
par alliance
nous sommes des as de la même famille
merci c'est gentil mais vous n'est ce
pas florent est pour ainsi dire de la
même famille
petit à petit tu me les présentera tout
ce qui m'était conté je pense voler de
façon seul cousin
étaient amants mise à mort tu en a
beaucoup d'autres
non mon cher et que le seul moi aussi
mon cher jacques je suis le seul jusqu'à
sept minutes
voici des noms je n'insinue rien je dis
que je suis le seul à m'en de florence
vous plaisantez flore je peux pas être
la maîtresse de son cousin
mais je suis pas son cousin je suis son
amant aucun lien de parenté entre vous
je peux vous le jurer
j'aime mieux sa flore j'attends des
explications moi aussi mes explications
mais d'explication de quelques questions
vous voulez que je vous explique
maintenant vous le savez est claire oui
vous êtes tous les deux dans ma vie
voilà
enfin vous savez la vérité égard il ya
longtemps que dure cette situation oui
et non c'est terrible qui croyais être
le sol jambes et avec deux hommes
pendant 1 an faut le faire et dès que
jacques je vais vous demander une faveur
ce sera peut-être la dernière mais on
est aussi là près de moi à 6 voilà
écoutez moi
là je vais vous demander de m'écouter
sans l'interrompre quand j'aurai fini de
parler vous pouvez dire tout ce que vous
voudrez vous pouvez me frapper
m'insulter je ne bougerai pas mais
auparavant juste en supplie écoutez moi
sans l'interrompre
voilà ce n'est ni la frivolité ni le
goût de la facilité qui me poussait à
faire ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait consciemment
vous savez combien il n'a pas été une
aventure heureuse alors comme la plupart
des autres ne sont pas non plus moi j'en
suis arrivé à la conclusion que la
solution idéale pour une femme
aussi c'est à vivre avec deux hommes les
deux hommes sont libres
la femme n'est jamais délaissé et aux
cadets 3 mai prouvent cette impression
de monotonie qui je dois d'être ensemble
recule danon nous sommes le droit de
vous dire qu'en ce qui me concerne moi
j'avais vu juste
j'ai été très heureuse pendant cette
année
et quoi qu'il en soit je vous en
remercie
mais vous même si vous voulez bien
oublier un instant votre colère une
pensée cas ce qu'il fut n'avez vous pas
dit heureux jacques su qu eric schimdt
nous étions alors tous les quoi j'ai pas
eu le courage de vous dire la vérité à
temps et vous l'avait apprise dans les
pires conditions en stage et comme une
faute et si j'en suis puni ce ne sera
que justice
mais je vous demande je vous demande un
an auparavant ne prenez pas de décision
trop rapide
réfléchissez dites-vous que somme toute
ce soit à presque rien et chercher à
parce que pour toi rien n'est changé
lorsque l'on découvre que l'on à un
associé
pis pour toi il ne compte pas existe pas
pour toi c'est pas pour moi mais pour
l'autre chacun deux nouveaux héros à
mais nous sommes deux nuls non nous
sommes mal compris je veux dire que vous
n'avez l'un et l'autre que moi enfin
c'est vous et que vous pouvez toujours
continuer à vous ignorez mais comment
empêcher l'imagination de travail et
comment ne pas se dire il ya une heure
peut-être il était là lohan on and on
alors ça je vous rassure tout si vous
aviez chacun bonjour vous les garder je
ne me permettrai jamais de passer une
heure avec un une heure avec l'autre et
oui on a des principes on n'a pas
moi qui déjà ne vit pas les jours où je
ne te vois pas non maintenant que je
sais non non je ne peux pas accepter
cette situation et mois pas davantage
laurent je voudrais poser une dernière
question l'idée de ce ménage à trois
t'es venu comment non simple question
pour la petite histoire c'est qu'on est
jacques le premier ensuite j'ai connu
éric ça fait jamais encore tendu les
l'idée de vivre avec deux hommes mais
elle était sans doute la tente en moi
vous êtes apparue elle s'est matérialisé
nous sommes tombés à pic
si vous n'avez pas rencontré nous
serions heureux maintenant marié
peut-être un couple comme les eaux où
marié à non non j'étais contre euro
votre malheureux enfin rien qu'il faille
regretter d'ailleurs tous regrettent
inutile ce fut une expérience
intéressante grâce à toi j'ai rajeuni
je croyais être arrivé à un âge où on
n'a plus rien à apprendre de la vie je
me je me trompais et c'est un jeune
homme qui te dis adieu adieu florent non
partez pas je vous en prie donnez vous
un petit peu de temps pour réfléchir
[Musique]
adieu
vient ni sont rencontrés
ma chérie mâché du bar un choc trop bien
plus que je suis bien contente pour toi
mais c'est grâce à toi j'ai daisy
j'allais partir pour le bureau le
téléphone c'est robert tu penses y
jettent et fait oublier mon porte
documents chez toi je monte le chercher
je tremblais comme une feuille
mais je reste très ferme n'en est pas
question et lui je montrais si je veux
est d'abord où es tu passé l'année j'ai
téléphoné chez toi toutes les heures
qu'il n'y était pas moi je dis rien et
lui grâce à cette nuit blanche qui va
plaire je te je t'adore tu m'appartiens
voilà qu'est ce que tu dis à ma chérie
je dicte la chance mais c'est grâce à
toi si jamais pas passer la nuit chez
toi je serais vraiment carburant père et
moi j'aurais gardé éric jacques de
comment ça tu les avais partir ensemble
mais mon dieu c'est vrai confie ce qui
s'est passé hier soir eric est revenu
nous n'avons pas entendu nous dormions
alors tout à l'heure forcément il est
venu pour récupérer sa soirée il est
tombé sur jard ils sont partis tous les
deux ils n'ont même pas compris tout
l'amour que j'avais pour eux omar shérif
ma chérie tu fais pas supporté que soit
malheureuse cours du mois à lui ai
trouvé que leur partenaire tu leur diras
quoi tu fais une femme exceptionnelle
que jamais elle en prouvant une comme
toi tu ne gagnes pas plaire d'abord été
perdus parce que c'est la peau retournée
à passer la porte au nez mais si on n'a
pas de voix une foule est bien avec
saveur sûrement revenir mais tu as perdu
tu raison et puis après eh ben ça c'est
au tour de robert voilà cette pratique
ou demain ce sera bien normal après tout
ce que tu auras fait pour moi je suis
dit fais moi robert je dirais qu'on a
pas besoin de lui un héros oublié son
porte documents très bien je lis faire
un paquet avec un bon tiens c'est
monsieur voulait trouver ci joint
je suis amplement priés de la peine et
je prends voyez que je peux voter blanc
ces réunions par robert on ne peut pas
qui va être mortellement vix là tu crois
mais tu donnes les pendre au père tu
viens je me demande si j'ai pas été trop
froide avec lui tout à l'heure alors si
on nous renvoie son porte-documents
comme ça je ne reverrai plus jamais mais
on n'a pas besoin d'être jalouse tu peux
pas supporter de voir heureuse tu veux
tout gâcher mes écoutes
on sait à marcher tu ne te belle plus de
mes affaires et moi je ne mets plus
détiennent tu es d'accord mais sam jeune
jury doit faire pour toi ça a des
repères je lui ai dit que je passait la
soirée chez toi et que je ne verrais que
de mal il n'a pas pu résister alors je
voudrais pas attendez savoir mais je
crois que c'est mon plombier
c'est sûrement messieurs compte si ces
trois messieurs krouchi non c'est plus
cher c'est amusant
tout ce que vous avez trouvé ce fait dix
mille fois comme la fesse j'étais juré
rick que mon plombier d'appel cros
cheese jure toujours tu n'en es pas un
mensonge
enfin peu importe si je suis revenu
c'est pour te dire qu'il est absolument
inutile de m'écrire ou de me téléphoner
tu m'entends est absolument inutile avec
moi quand c'est fini c'est bien fini
laissez moi vous expliquer tout est ma
faute
paul tétouan quand éric dit que c'est
fini c'est bien fini
exactement enfin on voit que tu ne
connais pas eric il ya une volonté de
faire cet art rock robert aussi est
traitée
robert s'agit bien de robert de l'ecn
par têtu il a de la volonté et ça c'est
très différent
n'est ce pas eric n'est ce pas assez
différent ce toit différents
bon si seulement tu pouvais employés
cette volonté pour essayer de comprendre
vous et vous devez en ans j'étais trop
déçu
merci alors at-on pour moi bien ses
bibis on écoute une gaffe tu sais pas
long il s'agit pas de billets veto
contre android y aurait ri qu'il a
compris maintenant qu'ils n'oublient all
we may cry j'ai une bonne idée
oui si tu rentres chez toi tu met à la
porte s'est passé 1 seulement j'aurais
parlé avec eric non rester pour le je
m'en vais j'ai dit à florence tout ce
que je vais lui dire alors
faudrait pas laisser tout seul ce père
qu'elle fasse une bêtise pour mais tu
vas te taire
tu vas perdit alors le chantage au
suicide attendait tous les conseillers
vont être parent c'est ma scène de
rupture
j'aimerais bien la jouer à ma manière tu
m'entends est-ce que tu montes on n'est
pas du genre qui se suicident aventure
regrette
ah non non mais enfin ça peut être très
flatteur ça c'est le pompier il
s'appelle vraiment gros si tu sais le
sauver lui dire qu'ils vont organiser
une petite fille de masse comme ça que
c'est bien contente d'un père tom sa
machine à porte malheur la salle de bain
c'est par là
laurent je suis simplement venu te dire
vous êtes là excusez moi je l'enlève
pour l'instant erikm la même idée de
vous mais lui il s'est buté cas je t'ai
dit pont no matter des vacheries laisse
m'apprend des choses en main
[ __ ] mais dis moi tu as chaud pierre
ne seriez pas là tous les trois sur
revenus pour des références que en ce
qui me concerne c'était fini et bien
fini
et vous évidemment c'est fini ou si la
référence jeu je voulais te dire que
j'ai été très heureux même si c'est fini
j'ai été très heureux et je voulais te
remercier pour ce bonheur
enfin voila moi aussi je voulais te
remercier
j'ai eu un an de bonheur je ne me plains
pas qu'est ce que c'est un an
qu'est ce que c'est non mais c'est 365
jours et 360 nuit m'avait donné 365
jours et 365 bonheur et j'en suis très
heureuse très triste et très heureuse
très triste parce que maintenant je vous
ai perdu et je vais me retrouver tout
seul mais très heureuse parce que vous
venez tous les deux de me remercier pour
ce bonheur partagé c'est fini c'est
dommage maintenant je voudrais
population va tout n'est peut-être pas
joué
vous aimez jouer et vous
[Musique]
je voudrais
peux tu as coach éric aux non merci
et toi non chérie non merci florence
asseyez-vous alors tu nous a convoqués
ensemble je n'avais pourtant aucune
envie de me retrouver en face de ce
monsieur quand je les entends votre
service il faudra que c'est important
florence n'aurait jamais commis de tels
l'indélicatesse aux deux bonnes raisons
asseyez-vous
[Musique]
puisque vous connaissez chacun
l'existence de l'autre j'ai pensé qu'il
valait mieux vous soyez ensemble pour
apprendre ce que j'ai à vous dire je
pense vous puissiez me reprocher quoi
que ce soit alors voilà je vous ai fait
venir parce que j'ai une proposition à
vous faire vous exigez tous les deux la
même chose vous voulez bien me pardonner
mais à une condition que notre vie
continue avec l'un mais pas avec l'autre
c'est bien ça c'est ce que je t'ai
proposés oui c'est une possibilité mais
en supposant même il n'est pas dit que
j'accepte mais là moi moi j'accepte vous
êtes sécurité alors vous acceptez eaux
profondes est il que florence vous
choisissent vous êtes un peu trop sûre
de moi vous allez avoir des désillusions
quand je connais florence je les aime
plus que tout moi aussi je l'aimé plus
que tout mais enfin c'est incroyable ça
vous vous croyez moi je vous aime tous
les deux et vous voulez qu'ils donnent
une quinzaine c'est pas facile comment
mieux que je pense recevoir choisir dans
la vie vous voulez pas qu'on recommence
comme avant
maintenant vous savez pas question
très bien alors je fais ma proposition
je vous promets de vous donner ma
réponse dans une semaine jour pour jour
mais à une condition c'est que pendant
cette semaine nous continuons comme
avant comme avant commença comme un ver
est le mardi le jeudi le samedi et toi
le lundi le mercredi et le vendredi
comme auparavant
remarquez qu'ils voulaient changer le
jour moi j'y vois peut-être qu'on vivra
tellement tu comprends eric si tu veux
changer ton samedi pour un autre jour
sauf que c'est un petit peu mieux parce
que par exemple si tu prends le vendredi
7 à venir de jeux de suite le jeudi et
le vendredi c'est pas très normal
puisque vous serez pas très gentils
parce qu'alors s'est fait chez les plus
jeunes du mercredi au samedi devant
jeudis vendredis samedis 2 et 3 juillet
non non non non non non décidément faut
rien changer
voilà vous êtes d'accord moi je t'ai dit
non tout de suite
moi je suis d'accord qu'on remercie mon
chéri merci mon chéri en ont mais c'est
agréable mais tu es d'accord aussi mou
c'est comment je suis d'accord je n'ai
jamais dit que j'étais d'accord a dit
malek jacques acceptes tu es bien
obligés d'accepter
sinon j'aurais l'air de refuser le
combat ça serait vraiment la première
fois ça mais ça il est vrai que j'aime
assez la bagarre qu'est ce qu'une
semaine apprendra plus a alors ça
j'allais le néant
je ne sais pas j'espère qu'une petite
lumière va surgir devant moi qui
montrera le bon chemin vers l'est vers
l'autre puisque vous l'exigez vous
l'exigez vraiment non mais tu le fais
exprès a fait au moins dix fois comme un
ami des bébés moi moi moi moi je les ai
joué non plus simplement je veux vivre
avec toi tout le temps et alors moi vous
me mettez ou moi
allez moi je m'occupe pas de vous mais
il pense qu'à lui ce type mais vous êtes
complètement à socialement lieu mais il
faut vous faire psychanalyser pas comme
ça vivent dans un cocon en effaçant les
autres il existe les autres alors alors
faudrait y penser
un loup mais vous vous rendez compte
vous vous rendez compte dans quelle
situation vous mettez vous me demandez
de choisir vous foutez là vous foncez
faut décider tout de suite comme ça sans
réfléchir
vous me dit d'une semaine oui pompage et
dj d'une semaine ce sera peut-être deux
trois six semaines si on veut vraiment
faire les choses sérieusement une
semaine donc il c'est mon dernier mot
c'est très bien de ta merde alors dans
une semaine alors comment fait-on qui
commence
quado je veux savoir lequel de vous deux
passera la première soirée avec moi ça
je ne veux savoir ise personnes toutes
les choses peut pas honnêtement très
bien on va tirer au sort pas une pièce
dont une aux pièces vous avez une pièce
raoui tient à florence en cela une main
innocente
bon alors un pilote fasse non à côté dit
pas la même chose alors payer pour
ammann fait que vous voulez très bien on
va faire ça ok pardon au pied tall et on
met un pied devant l'autre chacun son
tour aux achats et ça peut vous faire
plaisir alors celui qui met en son pied
en dernier celui d'autres à gagner dans
ce sport g guin forcément des plus
grandes ligues
j'en ai assez de temps de l'espoir de
jouer la lèche la première soirée
d'accord je la prends alors il est
comment ces gens non mais c'est juste
non maintenant il va le favoriser
vous avez le même nombre de soirées tu
commences jacques termine cette année
m oui c'est le dernier que rappeur les
chorales vont aussi l'affluence n'est
pas bon mais je préfère quand même être
le dernier il a dû rassembler pour le
premier deux derniers oui mais juste
après les amis vos photos avons ben oui
je suis comme ça je préfère quand même
changé il commence et je termine alors
l'accord est conclu je n'y reviens pas
le jeu et le jeu et je serai intraitable
je sais me battre quand il le faut moi
aussi je sais une patte mais loyalement
avec vous tout est truqué de l'état
d'avoir vous commencez par marcher
dessus avec mon grand club
alors vous n'avez qu'a vous retirer de
la compétition vous vous entendez on
dirait de monde autour d'un sac de
billes
je suis pas un jouet moi je ne suis pas
à gagner mais regardez vous rendez
compte que vous exigez mois sacré qui
est l'homme que j'aime vous me demandez
de choisir moi je veux bien mais l'eau
et moi mais moi je ne demande qu'à t d
mais il faut me comprendre
pour toi je voudrais être le seul et
l'unique
alors je voudrais bien aussi que pour
toi être le seul et l'unique
c'est normal mais oui c'est pour moi
mais tu le seul l'unique cours je
voudrais tant que tu comprennes je veux
bien comprendre je ne demande pas mieux
mais comment puis-je être le seul et
l'unique pour toi alors qu'il est encore
là lui mais c'est que vous êtes unis
tous les deux
mon dieu c'est difficile d'exprimer %
restent pas si loin moi tu comprends en
toi ce que j'essaie de dire
tu aimes deux hommes à la rigueur je
pourrais le comprendre mais il ya
forcément un que tu aimes davantage je
ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser que ton
préféré c'est moi alors flanche exigé
si c'est ont préfèré dit le tout de
suite parce qu'alors mois je m'en vais
n'écoutez pas de préféré vous voyez
c'est par vous même et vous non non et
vix n'est pas toi mon préféré
ni toi jacques non je n'ai pas préféré
jeune et je n'ai que deux grands amours
finement reste une semaine une toute
petite semaine pour profiter du bonheur
de vous avoir encore tous les deux après
je n'aurai plus le droit d'aimer qu'un
seul et c'est alors que je me sentirais
tout seul
quelques jours sommes-nous mercredi
jacques c'est ton jour
es-tu passé la soirée avec moi ah non je
regrette je commence il m'a cédé son
tour enfin si nous avions été jeudi ses
tatouages aurait demandé de passer la
fête c'est quand même préférable un beau
tirage au sort là tu crois pas non je ne
crois rien je constate simplement qu'il
favoriserait bien gens retournent chez
moi j'ai un très bon livre sur les
aztèques comme après c'est charlie ça me
changera toutes les histoires de bonne
femme salue os
tiens
c'est pour toi
tu es fou elle ne te plaît pas tu
terminais mes l'aï dit moi s'il te plaît
elle est merveilleuse mais tu t'es
ruinée elle t'a coûté au moins beaucoup
moins que ça ne soit pas acceptée
pourquoi si c'est pas toi que je choisis
tu me seraient attachées jeter la
rendrait j'aurai plus de mal
qu'aujourd'hui même si je ne suis pas
choisi jour et que la carte
j'avais apporté à tout hasard ce soir
qu'il te reste quelque chose de moi on
parle pas comme ça parle pas de
séparation ce jeu c'est de préparer au
pire
je pensais au pie ix et parce que le
meilleur look a mal agi faire toi fond
de tristesse
regarde moi c'est vrai moi je suis gay
suis je suis consciente
je pense pas toujours aux événements qui
peuvent survenir j'avoue qui a les nerfs
solides mois dans ta situation je
n'aurais pas vécu tu as une arme forte
non non non non je suis faible et plein
de défauts au fait qu'on vous par
exemple je connais mes défauts jeunes
tout en toi je ne sais même pas ce que
ce qu'on peut appeler qualité ou ce
qu'il faut appeler défaut tu as le temps
de te transformer à mon avantage près de
toi je me sens toujours merveilleusement
innocente c'est comme ça que je t'aime
sur rien mais tu me fais vivre dans un
monde trop protégé j'abandonne la
défense alors forcément quand je
retourne dans la vraie vie celle des
autres j'arrive marc méchant soit de
mauvais coups je sais pas une raison
pour je me force à temps donné aussi
d'ailleurs j'en serai mais si tu étais
plus sévère avec moi sans doute serait
plus gentille certaines fois je te fais
du mal que parce que tu ne m'en fais pas
non mais c'est terrible ce que tu dis la
vérité je n'ai pas envie de te faire
souffrir qui devrait et conseils d'amis
tiens je serai dans mon essai par nom
reste celui que tu es m e - protège moi
j'ai besoin de toi
j'ai besoin que tu aime rire voire
magique près de toi je me sens meilleur
que je ne suis plus intelligente plus
forte
je sais bien que l'image est trompeuse
mais je me laisse tromper avec délice
ces moments sont indispensables à mon
bonheur
qui sait peut-être sont-ils tout mon
bonheur peut-être le bonheur est-il la
somme de tous ces
où l'on s'est créé différents de ce que
l'on naît alors tu es heureuse avec moi
tu dois vivre en pensant que tu me
donnes quelque chose d'irremplaçable que
personne d'autre que toi ne pourrait me
donner que si je perdais mon amour je
serai la plus malheureuse des femmes
tu dois vivre avec cette idée en toi que
tu as mon sort entre des mains que tu
que tu peux me brisez que je dépends de
toi que tu es unique au monde a eu au
monde mais pas dans ta vie dont dans ma
vie si je n'ai jamais connu d'hommes
comme toi a su rien d'extraordinaire je
vais te faire la liste de tes qualités
n'ont pourtant repris par le bosniaque
toi qui me tairai voilà grande qualité
que tu as celle là je les biens je ne
suis sûr de rien sauf de ce site est mon
seul centre d'intérêt je suis là comment
dire spécialisé doctoresse florence
agrégé ès florence et peut-être bientôt
licenciés
ce regard que tu viens d'avoir je sens
que vous me rendrai très malheureux mais
j'accepte d'aller ailleurs prendre un
verre avec vous c'est la première phrase
que tu m'as dit le jour où nous le
sommes rencontrés avec le même regard
qu'il y à un instant souvenez pas je ne
m'étais pas trompé tu regrettes de
m'avoir adressé la parole ce soir mais
non non jamais je verrai sept années
passées avec toi si tu veux dit jacques
ce n'est pas toi que j'ai choisis tu
n'auras pas besoin d'ajouter restons
bons amis parce que je resterai ton ami
pour toujours
il pourra m'appeler à n'importe quelle
heure du jour et de la nuit je viendrai
si tu te sens seul si tu as besoin de
confier ta joie ta peine n'importe quoi
ce soir je fais un serment jusqu'à la
fin de ma vie tous les lundis les
mercredis les vendredis que dieu fera je
resterai seul je penserai à toi c'est
trop je ne mérite pas ce sacrifice
regardez le feu à écouter le goûter les
heures s'écoulent ton épaule s'alourdir
sur la mienne
parfois souvent souvent mais désire kimo
vendre mon ami et moi on m'a dit
pourquoi pourquoi il faut que tout ceci
se termine
moi je veux je veux je veux tu aimais
encore je me sens capable de surmonter
toutes les difficultés de vaincre tous
les autres secteurs
j'en hackers il y en a qu un griot et
mais tu le sais pas mais chine qu'il
allait peut-être après et après mais
c'est terrible pour moi est ce que tu te
rends compte
je me rends compte que c'est pas
possible c'est pas c'est pas possible
j'ai pas le droit
j'ai pas le droit de faire ça tu
comprends je t'aime et je suis bonne
qu'à faire souffrir oui c'est sur le
toit moi je suis heureux non mais tu as
bien réfléchi ne voudrais pas pu aider
regret un décret ne délivrera pas le
temps d'y penser
parce que je vais épouser attise ya
toujours un j'y tiens parce l'exigent
enfin le mariage complet en nous ce sera
différent
mais parce que ce sera toi parce que ce
sera moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est pour toi je les avais oubliés dans
la voiture et puis je me suis dit que je
m'étais conduit comme un imbécile tout à
l'heure puis je pensais que ce serait
mieux chez toi voilà mes ciric
c'est la première fois que tu m'apportes
des fleurs mieux vaut tard
non je m'en vais autant le dire tout de
suite quoi
florence quelque chose à vous dire
eric écoute j'ai choisi jacques non
je regrette je n'accepte pas les soins
t'explique
on l'avait dit lu ça mais je suis mais y
avait je vous laisse tomber florence à
vous expliquer je rentre chez moi à
peine moins cher et je reviens désormais
7 à la date d'aujourd'hui que je fêterai
mon anniversaire
parce que c'est aujourd'hui que ma vie
commence vraiment je suis navré pour
vous mon vieux
quel faux derche
ma vie commence vraiment avec des
salades pareil qu'il t'a eu quel bar à
thym minable non j'ai compris que
c'était lui simplement
mais aujourd'hui je n'accepte pas je me
courir ma chance
aussi je reviendrai demain comme prévu
après tu choisiras non avec c'est
définitif
je ne changerai pas d'avis bon bien tu
vas leur maman chérie mois malheureux
alors là je me demande bien pourquoi la
femme que j'aime le veut plus de moi je
la vois pour la dernière fois pour la
dernière fois je pose mes yeux sur ce
corps sur ce visage tu voudrais que ce
soit malheureux j'ai tout jeune âge dans
la joie mais elle est quand même dans
l'eau ça se passe vite aussi les fleurs
pourquoi te faire du mal inutilement
je sais très bien que ma présence
n'était pas agréable passé par brest
tu le sais très bien enfin le principal
c'est que les erreurs sont tus heureuse
oui annoncé oui ou oui oui oui oui oui
je suis heureuse
enfin comment veux tu que je sois
heureuse quand je te vois dans cet état
bon eh bien je m'en vais adieu florence
et bonne chance
bonne chance à toi aussi eric
on a l'air vec comme ça a dit que
florence
on s'embrasse bien sûr
non pourquoi tu ne vas plus m'embrasser
à pacy mais bon comme ça alors du mois
comment on écoute on sait qui est à dieu
et bonne chance alors tout va bien c'est
fini tu as peur peur de quoi peur de
m'embrasser tu as peur de flancher tu
n'es pas sûr de toi
pas du tout ma décision est prise
n'essaie pas de me faire changer d'avis
qu'il n'y arrivera pas je n'essaie rien
du tout je me demande simplement si tu
as vraiment sûr de toi
oui je suis sûr de moi alors tu peux
m'embrasser non mais pourquoi puisque tu
es sûr de toi non as tu n'es pas sûr de
toi
florence il s'agit de ma vie et de mon
bonheur alors je peux pas accepter de
tout perdre comme ça si je ne suis pas
absolument certain tu ne te trompe pas
sur tes propres sentiments
eco terre et que j'ai bien réfléchi
maintenant j'y vois clair tu dois me
croire alors prouve le mois embrasse moi
ah bon parce que pour toi un désistera
bah oui parce que si tu ne le fais pas
c'est qu'au fond de toi rien n'est
encore décidé
comme ça tu le rates après 1
mais ben alors tu m'embrasses oui
bon bah t'es content maintenant et toi
moi ça va très bien tu es toujours
décidé toujours alors embrassement
encore toujours toujours assez déloyale
ça va tu continues moi je crie les
macrophages bien
et puis cris maintenant au eric quoi
j'avais pris ma décision
on s'est embrassés c'est lui on s'est
dit au revoir et je t'attends là
un bébé éprouvette nantais disais tout à
l'heure c'était une preuve alors tu peux
pas partir comme ça mais puisque c'est
jacques peux tu as joué des coudes et
liquidée il faut que tu comprennes tu
meures a dit pas quand tu te rendais pas
compte dans les comptes de poids est
content que toi que que quelques mois
que toi comme moi ça veut dire quoi que
tu vois que moi que je t'aime sortie
publique reste avec moi ce soir ce soir
est avec moi toujours oui mais c'est
nouveau ça va voilà en somme qui a
changé de mains ça veut dire que ces
mots qu a choisi jacques au téléphone
oui tout de suite
des nouveaux qu'est ce que je vais lui
dire devine enfin je veux dire comment
je vais lui dire oh mais comme tu veux
tu veux les coûts terre au halo jacques
oui c'est moi non non non tout va bien
enfin non tout va pas bien voilà je
téléphone parce que j'ai oui j'ai changé
d'avis j'ai réfléchi c'est pas possible
nous deux je choisirais - maria fait
ça ne fait pas trop de peine ou excuse
moi je te poses des questions idiotes
bien sûr que j'ai du chagrin
alors écoutez je crois que pour nous
trois il vaut mieux plus qu'on se revoit
on va manger ligne voilà pierreux ça va
et du même mais oui bien sûr que non je
suis à toi rien quatre heures il faudra
que tu m'aimes petit mais beaucoup parce
que moi j'ai besoin
mais oui j'ai besoin qu'on aime beaucoup
beaucoup mais france tu crois pas que tu
radote un peu et toitures oui mais m
florence tu as l'air si fatigué je vais
te laisser maintenant avec tout ça il
est traité je tourne de sommeil alors
demain je viendrai te chercher comme
prévu mais soient prêtes tu à paris x et
toi que j'ai choisi moi alors il pourra
cubaines ont mérité leur bien parce
qu'elles sont mais leurs habitudes
liquide et tu vas aller au lit seul et
demain une nouvelle vie comme mon nom je
vais pas dormir et avec west ham
tu vas aller au lit avec un bon sinon on
reste avec moi je ne veux pas dormir et
blanc je sens qu'ils font je me faut
c'est fini c'est fini
c'est fini oui eh bien tu vois quand tu
es raisonnable tout va beaucoup mieux
alors maintenant tu vas aller sagement
au lit en pensant à noir compris
voilà auto n'y a pas de téléphone pas
été sauvée c'est peut-être eux chat
vous lui avez bien dit que j'étais là
mais oui mais elle m'a dit qu'elle ne
viendrait que lorsqu'il serait là tous
les deux ah oui pis elle a même ajouté
vous direz un pool qu'elle parte avant
qu'il n'arrive il à votre avis le
pilates est choisi je vais vous dire
j'en sais rien maintenant d'abord on a
cru que cette l1 après on a cru que
c'était l'autre puis finalement on est
reparti de zéro paul nous avions aussi
entend il vient du tout elle ne m'a rien
dit moi vous me connaissez un il ya
quelque chose dans l'air
aussitôt ce m'aperçois pneus long là
rien c'est affreux j'arrive pas à
supporter cette incertitude
non moi vous savez ça me fait comme une
boule ont vivement tout à l'heure qu'on
sache
et puis pense organiser lequel at elle
choisi
n'oubliez pas que c'est jacques hommos
crois rien font très bien trop fatigant
n'a voté hérité plus plus énergique plus
plus viril mais je suis tendu romantique
mange avec à sa place j'hésiterais aussi
un maillot oui je suis très inquiète
or si j'avais choisi eric est capable de
faire une bêtise c'est un violent
parfois il me fait peur vous avez raison
j'aurais peut-être dû dire à mon mari de
venir et oui téléphonez we weed au nom
au nom non maintenant ces trotteurs
nourries vont arriver d'un instant à
l'autre j'ai vraiment par madame alliot
si jacques n'ai pas choisi il est
capable de se suicider c'est tous les
couteaux autres
le laisser traîner aucun objet dangereux
plus grosse andrieu attachés l'un en va
en bon peut tout de même pas suicidé
avec ap cendrier d'innocence il suffit
de le jeter en l'air et s'arranger pour
leur sofa l'un sur la tempe
vous avez raison avait pas pensé à ça
aux hausses des grandes villes
pouf la pop est néanmoins il peut tout
de même pas le lancer en l'air très bien
fermé non se vérifier oui oui et vous
vous bougez pas devant votre fourneaux
pourquoi s'il arrache le trio de gaza
non à l'homme ça je vais pas rester que
dans le fourneau non non non serait
derrière la porte c'est ma place comme
ça si je pense quelque chose
aussitôt j'arrive vous croyez que vous
entendrez bien ben c'est la meilleure
place français si j'ai l'habitude de là
on entend tout ce qui se dit si je me
dis avec vous dit rien la porte
ah ben non madame indique que vous
partir oui mais moi c'est uniquement
pour rendre service il faut en maîtriser
ce serait peut-être pas trop beau on
verra leur ne vous montrez pour enfin en
cas de danger à l'année d'avant cas chez
vous et attention à putney pourquoi
quand je rentrerai dans la cuisine
attention votre nez pourquoi mais parce
que la porte s'ouvre comme ça alors je
vais mener dessus
sur marc florand j'étais pas là et lit
dans sa chambre et les commandes
annoncées elles ne vous a pas parlé de
moi non si mauvais si elle nous a pas
parlé de moi du tout mais non je vous
assure
moi je voudrais bien vous est agréable
mais je vous assure que j'ai rien
entendu
si mauvais si mais non elle n'a pas
parlé de l'autre non plus vous savez ah
non non absolument pas vous voulez mon
avis oui je vous en prie donnez le moi
et bien j'aurai 100 francs à parier
serait pas sur lequel mise et ça c'est
monsieur hery on vous croyez que c'est
lui si je peux bien vous pensez que
c'est lui non c'est pas pu 8 vous il
faut pourtant que soit l'avis de ne sais
pas ah ben oui ça c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'on peut dire bonsoir mais amadio
non ce n'est pas dans sa chambre elle
est comme un allongé
vous lui avez parlé ah non elle a dit
qu'elle ne viendrait qu'en vous seriez
là tous les deux elle vous a parlé moins
bon c'est vrai ça pas un mot alors c'est
vous j'espère obala pas parler de lui
non plus hein
alors ça c'est bon signe ah vous voyez
tout à l'heure vous disiez que c'est
mauvais signe
faut pas avoir des mauvais signe comme
ça partout bon vous êtes prêts c'est un
chercheur
c'est là qu'elles sont là et bien jolie
elle arrive
mais si la cour merci de plaisanter non
je veux jouer je crois que ça vaut mieux
excuse-moi florence je ne trouve rien de
drôle à dire ce qu'elles réagissent
selon son tempérament mais il m'arrive
d'être très amusant l'aspap le week-end
et parfois très drôles parfois si tu
veux que je plaisante je peux faire un
effort
si tu fais un déport ai dit que
j'aimerais que ce soit toi aussi jacques
j'aimerais que ce soit pour comprendre
je vais vous décevoir
terriblement témoins tous les deux tous
les deux tous les deux vous m'avez
demandé de choisir je n'ai pas pu
jusqu'à la dernière minute j'ai été bien
je n'ai pas pu c'est navré d'avoir à
vous le dire mais je vous aime autant
l'un que l'autre
je peux pas choisir sur ma tête sur le
billot je ne pourrais pas absolument
absolument sûr merci mon fait merci mon
chéri tu dis moi je t'avoue qu'on était
très inquiet oui un moment j'ai cru que
ce serait moi j'ai cru que ce serait lui
qui compte c'est le plus beau jour de
notre vie
oui le plus beau jour puisque c'est
aujourd'hui que tu nous a vraiment
choisi
je comprends pas il ya huit jours vous
ne voyez pas et payman même maintenant
vous n'en êtes vous sûr de m'avoir bien
compris je ne peux pas choisir entre
vous deux
mais rassure toi nous avons compris le
dire que je ne veux pas vivre uniquement
à une grille mais je sais ça veut dire
que je ne peux pas des poux n'ai jamais
fait et c'est ça qui vous rend si
heureuse mais où il cessa avant très
bientôt maman moi je comprends plus rien
c'est normal a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour que tu te doute de rien un
moment j'ai cru que j'avais donné un nom
alors ça rien du tout hachez pas
mécontent que ça soit fini et vous êtes
d'accord pour qu'on vive comme un an
mais bien sûr évidemment si vous en ai
pas de savoir que deux
vous êtes bien sûr que non vous êtes
vraiment des hommes étonnant plus
étonnant encore que tu ne crois c'est
toi qui lui parlent ces annonces et toi
c'est vous nous avons notamment un peu
menti mais pas pour le plaisir de mentir
non dans un but supérieure voilà en
vérité et luc et moi nous nous
connaissons depuis de longues années
ah oui ensemble nous avons fait les 400
coups et puis la vie nous a séparés
éric s'est marié moi j'ai cherché à le
faire un jour par hasard nous nous
sommes retrouvés à nous avons fait le
bilan
le mariage d'eric avait été un échec et
sa vie de célibataire n'était pas nous
réussit mais c'est pour ça que nous
étions tristes tiens j'en vois la scène
nous étions au silencieux le nez dans
notre verre de whisky quand éric m'a dit
maman vient il faut se rendre à
l'évidence un homme n'a pas assez a
donné pour combler une femme et moi
j'avais répondu il est par contre une
femme assez de générosité en elle pour
rendre heureux deux hommes et oui vie
des halles serait donc deux hommes et
une femme
oui mais il faudrait que les deux hommes
soient de véritables amis avec des
caractères différents mais
complémentaires
alors les deux jeunes nous les avions
oui nous manquait la femme et c'est
alors que vous avez rencontrées vous
l'avez tous compris en france et
l'extraordinaire dévoués que je
comprends vie est merveilleuse
ce que j'admire le plus haut moi c'est
mon intuition je suis vraiment
merveilleuse
il aura suffit tout juste d'un an qu'on
a percé pas de rien eh bien vous vous
êtes bien des chinois
je ne veux pas du tout mais au contraire
russie vient ton évolution avait
beaucoup de mon gros si tu savais tout
le bien qu en fonction de toi cette
brave petite florence bête
même si gentil mais pas du tout je ne te
permet pas de dire du mal de toi tu n'en
as pas de quoi tuer une femme
exceptionnelle d'ailleurs on s'en est
tout de suite rendu constituent ce que
jacques m'a dit aussitôt après tard a
rencontré cette fois ci mon vieux je
crois que ça y est aussi à l'oiseau rare
une femme intelligente sont si
l'indépendant dégoûté du mariage et qui
plus est ravissant ah oui oui avec elle
ça devrait être possible alors il ne me
restait plus qu'à faire ta connaissance
est apte à séduire à monte je suis pas
fier de moi si vous saviez vous avez dû
penser cette femme là on l'a commencée
comme mais pas du tout d'ailleurs qui
nous a prouvé le contraire
tout ça a été fidèle pendant toute cette
année comment le situe comme eric et moi
nous n'avons pratiquement pas quitté
je nous aurais tu drop et c'est à dire
que j'en aurais vraiment pas eu le temps
pourquoi n'avez vous pas dit tout de
suite que vous connaissez par prudence
ou et puis les femmes qu'elle s'en
défende ou non sont exclusives
conventionnelle et notre système était
assez révolutionnaire
enfin s'il fallait te le faire admettre
progressivement et mieux te faire croire
que tu l'avais inventé toi-même soit 10
en vente et vous me l'avez fait croire
et que nous avons senti que tu étais
prête à la mettre ouvertement alors là
nous nous sommes arrangés pour nous
rencontrer chez toi
est-ce que ça aussi c'était arrangé
vous n'allez pas me dire que vous avez
payé robert
non nous avons seulement exploiter les
circonstances à cause de paul j'avais
raté ma soirée avec toi ça c'était prévu
le lendemain pour la récupérer qu'il
savait très bien que jacques était là et
oui oui bien vous m'avez menti d'un bon
ballon
nous avons peut-être employer les moyens
critiquable mais c'était pour la bonne
cause nous être sûrs que tous nous
aimait autant l'enclos et voilà pourquoi
nous avons un peu menti florence normand
tir c'est un bien grand mot pas tout dit
voilà bah faut dix albums france
maintenant que tu connais la vérité
dieuze mais n'oblige et oblige oui enfin
est en femme donc logique
je suis coincé je voulais tous les deux
je vous ai conclusion je suis heureuse
c'est l'état bonheur tout ce qu'il y à
deux logiques alors que tu me déçois
quoi je m'attendais un peu plus
d'enthousiasmé un peu de patience and
est encore sous le coup de la révélation
l'esprit y est on sûr mais je crois que
que le mieux c'est que nous ne laissions
te reposer ce soir demain nous
commencerons à profiter de notre bonheur
à florence tu ne vois pas d'inconvénient
à ce que nous gardions les mêmes jours
pas d'inconvénient non
moi vous savez du moment que c'est
logique alors je te dis à demain et mois
après nous aussi si tu savais comme
c'est plus agréable pour nous deux de
pouvoir partir ensemble et sans avoir à
se cacher
a lâché riches n'en vient pas forcément
tu n'es pas sorti desquelles tout espoir
mais je te pardonne mais moi je te parle
de ces deux là or je ne croyais pas mes
oreilles je n'en croyais pas mon oreille
alors donc je n'en croyais pas mon
oreille devenir une porte on ne peut
écouter qu'avec une oreille pas avec les
deux femmes un moral d'acier toi
plaisanter parce qu'on vient d'entendre
mais si j'étais à ta place je nous sens
trader à oui alors mes pleurs que les
dons mais oui il mérite une leçon à oui
alors ouais mais je comprends pas parce
qu'ils ont bien fait chez toi kg à
réagir avec mesquinerie mais il pouvoir
le fond des choses
nous sommes partis et moi de la même
idée à savoir qu'une femme ne peut pas
être heureuse avec un seul homme mais
cette idée là ses deux fils ont eu les
premiers c'est pas toi
aucune importance l'essentiel c'est
d'être d'accord sur le principe
prenez c'est pas tout embrouiller 1
moi ce que je constate c'est que les
menteurs ce sont eux mot c'est une autre
morale
nous avons tous menti et pour une bonne
raison c'est parfait nous croyons que
mais bon on admettrait par le système
est alors maintenant maintenant que tout
le monde l'admet alors
bon du moment vous êtes heureux et qu'on
sait sur quel pied danser tout à l'heure
là sur le coup je me disais heureux
seulement parce que je ne voyais pas de
nos deux raisons de ne pas l'être ou
alors maintenant on attend maintenant
que moi nous sommes d'accord sur le
principe je le suis spontanément
maintenant tout est plus simple et des
choses des choses merveilleuses vont
être face des choses merveilleuses alors
oui c'est pleurant voilà je vous appelle
parce que finalement j'ai trouvé un
petit moment pour vous rencontrer
seulement chez moi si vous conviendra il
est charmant
il dit que même si c'est à 5 heures du
matin il est d'accord
non rassurez-vous mitage et dimanche
après midi alors voilà ce que je vous
propose
vous venez me prendre vers 2 heures de
l'après midi et puis on ira voir un
petit match de football c'est les
gentils dit qu'ils n'aiment pas le
football mais qu'avec moi il va
l'aborder
oui alors après après eh bien nous
reviendront chez moi pour prendre le thé
les merveilles ou ludiques c'est
merveilleux mais voilà des mots jeudi
je sens vous n'êtes pas d'accord toutes
les deux bah oui je sais je sais
jusqu'ici je m'étais toujours gardé mon
petit dimanche pour moi mais qu'est ce
que vous voulez moi j'avais pas d'autres
jours à lui proposer
la pièce que nous venons de jouer et de
claude reichmann
dans un décor de pierres simonini
avec des costumes de donald duck avril
[Applaudissements]
dans une mise en scène de rené clair
avec madeleine d'amiens
michel le royer
ivan clech
dominique patinoire
et régime blair
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]